do you wanna know it's Nadia troll then
everybody know the dicho bismillah
alhamdulillah Salam alaikum peace be on
to you thank you for tuning in to
another episode of the Deen show from
time to time we sometimes we answer some
of your questions we have so many
important issues that we're dealing with
here on the Deen show and we encourage
you to come back here every week and if
you don't catch us on the TV station you
can go to the Deen show com where all of
our shows are there now we come back
we're going to be answering a question
from a sister she got out of a
relationship one that she shouldn't have
been in but she learned from it and now
she's trying to cope because she's
having some effect some negative effects
that have come up from this and she
wants some advice so we got an expert on
the Deen show to give us some of that
advice we're gonna be reading out her
question we come back and helping
everyone benefit from the answers sit
tight we'll be right back
this is 13 the deegeu
this is the main you know this is the
things is the teacher this is the days
of the theme this is the theme Salaam
alaikum peace be with you but I can
still a look at what okay hum did Allah
praises to the creator of the heavens on
earth last time I saw you I think it was
in India or no I even saw you I think
after that in Canada but before that
India and now you're back in Chicago on
the Deen show yes yeah but it's good to
see you Eddie it's good to see you too
thank you once again thank you thank you
for having so now tell us a little about
you so most of the people the Muslims
they know who you are and can you I just
for our not yet Muslim audience and
those who you know the first time
getting a chance to tune in and and see
you here tell us a little about your
social well you know you refer to me as
the shear shear phase is a title that's
not like milkshake you know as you know
that there is no concept of clergymen in
Islam there isn't there is no okay it
and this idea is supposed to be very
liberating nobody comes between you and
your Creator okay you do not need an
operator it's a direct call so Islam
rejects the whole notion of clergymen so
a chef Imam is a title that is given to
person like myself when the community
feels that you're worthy of it and it's
just a title out of respect that this
person knows a little about the theology
of the religion and we can ask them
questions so the title is really just to
indicate um to indicate that you got a
lot of money so Sheikh and also be a
tribute to the guy who's got a big
bankroll like a like a prince or someone
like that is that also yes that worth
share can either refer to a religious
scholar an elderly person a head of a
group specifically a tribe or sometimes
in some places like in the Middle East
it is you know heads of a nation of
people who
two big families who are you know
leading a nation they can also be called
um cheese so anyways so there are two
ways to become a chef and I went to
school I got my degree in stomach
studies and then I got my degree in
psychotherapy yeah and now I'm
practicing psychotherapy so masha'Allah
so time is short we're gonna from time
to time we answer some of the viewers
questions okay so we have a question
here from a sister so I'm going to go
ahead and read it and then we can
diagnose it and hopefully inshallah you
can go ahead we give the the answer to
this question the sisters saying that I
have been in a very long relationship
with a boy and we have broken up
alhamdulillah all thanks to God I've
learned from my mistakes and understood
why girlfriends / boyfriends are and in
Arabic she used the word Haram which
obviously means prohibited in Islam my
question is to you how do I move on
although I know everything happens and
the will of God it is hard for me to put
this past it is hard for me to put this
in the past and move on I put my trust
in God but it seems as though it is
always on my mind every second I think
about this boy and the relationship that
we had I really am trying to work on
being a better Muslim but I don't know
the steps to take to move on I'm sure
many other girls are going through the
same thing similar situations so I would
kindly appreciate some advice to help
out the other sisters as well as myself
Eddie let me begin by thanking you for
creating such a safe place what people
can actually send in their questions and
that is it just says a lot about about
the show when people trust us with
something as intimate and as personal as
this it means that we're doing something
right so I congratulate thank well thank
you Marsha and I also appreciate you
know what the sister has done here and
that is look I've got an issue and I'm
reaching out for help somebody was
acknowledging that we have made I have
made a mistake in the past but I'm also
acknowledging the fact that I am still
stuck in my past and I am unable to to
move on so I really appreciate this um
this letter let me just begin by where
she ended up by saying that she
recognizes that
it's how long so what happens is that
nowadays the whole idea of you know
Islam teach us that there's got to be a
distance between the genders I mean that
we keep we keep a safe distance men and
women keep a distance and that distance
is both symbolic emotional as well as
physical if a man wants to be with a
woman there is nothing wrong with that
all we ask for is that you add an
ethical component to this potential
relationship and that ethical component
to it is the idea that we want to grow
spiritually into this and we're going to
publicly acknowledge and commit to one
to one another but that is what's
happening in our ways is you know this
whole notion of people being in love and
you know what they say people are you
know a man and a woman they first see
each other and then they immediately
fall what enough no they fall in bed
before they work so this is this is what
we see coming bad before they follow
exactly so it's more of a lust now
exactly and and you know it's funny
because they say that men use love to
get sex and women use sex to get love
Wow a woman thinks that if she has sex
with a guy that is going to cause him to
love her and if a guy tells a woman that
he loves her he knows that this is
what's going to get him the sex
so it's interestingly how our society
has really mixed the whole idea of sex
and love where it's almost if you have
sex it means that you are in love well
if that's the case then what do we call
rape if sex equals love then what's rape
too much love well of course it's not
yeah so so Islam teaching us that you
know what keep a distance between the
opposite between the genders and again
this distance is really for the
protection for the protection of all and
nowadays what we see you know this idea
of the relationships that people have
out there you know they say that there
is a relationship that we call
connection and that is you see a person
and you admire their physical appearance
and you fall in love
not with who the person is but rather
what the person is and that is their
physical appearance so we are connected
to the person due to their flush or to
the flesh we can only speak about them
in in in physical terms or like that
were widely like oh you know what she's
got this and she's got that so we can
only speak about the other person in
physical terms and that is terrible
because we only see their usefulness but
not their goodness and that's a terrible
relationship to be in and sometimes we
connect to people simply because of
their wealth or I like him because he
buys me stuff all the time I like him
because he pays for the dinners all the
time he fills my gas all the time but
that is the extent of it we cannot talk
to about the person beyond their
usefulness to us and that is really and
that is really terrible a healthy
relationship is a relationship we have
both parties care for the development
for the well-being and for the growth
and the happiness of one another that is
a healthy relationship but it's not just
healthy because of this but most
important because it has that ethical
value in into it so when people when
people you know go out and into these
types of relationships and they break
with with one another whether it was an
ethical relationship or not it sounds
like the sister has really given a piece
of her heart to this person and she is
heartbroken at this point because he
remains in her heart but he is out of
her life so how do we help that sister
and that's a crucial question we're
going to be answering this and more here
on the Dean show sit tight don't go
nowhere I am not afraid to stand alone
if Eliza
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if Allah is by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone
if allies by my side I am not afraid to
stand alone
iserlohn Dios Herrera solo yeah nah so
classic I would go to my room lock the
door go straight and cry thank God you
know me better than myself show me the
right way and I will not look like I
would leave everything behind a lot of
that greater and it creates everything
it gives intelligence to people Mohammed
is one of the last messengers since we
got back here on the Dean show with che
Yossef as Agha please continue where you
left off shake right so like we said
this is a person that will most likely
always have a place in that sister's
heart sound like you know she committed
to him and she was there and she admired
the person loved the person and we don't
question that that um that part of it
and you know she's saying that you know
she admitted that the relationship to
begin with was not really the best of
relationships to get um to get into so
what we have now is that this is what we
would consider to be a loss of a loved
she is asking how do I survive a loss of
Allah she is going what we go through
the stages of grief and basically when a
loss takes place we human beings we go
through five stages the first stage
being shock and denial oh my god it has
not happened so we're not we're not
really we have not realized that we have
not accepted it so a person would look
numb during that stage like staring all
the times like I can't believe it I just
can't believe it
they may not even be able to cry because
they're just the shock is just so
amazing well that may last for a long
time short time then the next stage is
it they get it till it is no longer um
there so there is a lot of anger and
resentment that takes place as a result
of the acceptance of the of the loss and
then we go into a depression and that is
recognizing that the anger has not done
us any good so we go into depression and
you know we've lost it it's not coming
back again
in it is reality at this at this at this
point and then after that we try to make
peace you know how do I make peace with
my past you know where do I find
meanings and then we go into acceptance
and being able to to UM to move on so
again it's very human that we go through
these stages to make sure that we heal
well now there is really no science as
to how long we stay in each stage some
people stay in one stage longer than
others we cruise through some but by
means of observation we will all go
through these um stage so to the to the
sister I would say do not rush yourself
out of it in a sense that do not have
what we call a flight to health go
through the natural the natural ways of
how we human beings deal with some with
our loss accept the fact that this
person will always have a place in your
heart and when we say except we're not
we're not branding it was approval but
that is just part of reality at this
point to talk to her about all you
should have never been there would not
really do any good it's already it's
already over but we can address our
sisters who have not been in these types
of relationships to be careful about
that but since she is the one that asks
the question as they accept that fact so
don't think that when I forget about him
that's where I am he'll know it is when
you accept and you come in peace um was
the past that is when a person is is
healing
so I'd say please do not rush yourself
out of it continue as you said you know
I'm trying to be a better Muslim as well
and as we've tried to squeeze you know
bad emotions from us the only way to
squeeze these bad emotions is by
actually instilling positive emotions in
our life so the more happen as we bring
in you know the more misery we squeeze
out of us so that's what we want to do
you know do a lot of go to yourself so
that the negative feelings will start
will start going away tell us for you
see this problem happening a lot in
today's culture and society where we
know that Islam
encourages you to go ahead and marry if
you need to you know you have this
desire to do it in a constructive way
with within the bounds that the crater
is pleased with within marriage now if
if in a society where it's just just
normal and there's a lot of peer
pressure you have a lot of people who
are just dating and it's natural it's
something that you know it's just normal
how can the youth or even just young
adults or even adults not fall into this
trap yep if you remember Eddie in the
very first time that I came on your show
we spoke about the whole idea of the
subjugation of the passion I mean that
is just one beautiful teaching that
Islam has for us and that is recognized
the challenge we cannot and here is the
sad reality we cannot scape it you know
it's like porn it's like um these are
all it's just all over the place it's
right on your face we cannot scape it
but we have the choice to reject it so
what we would say is yes accept the fact
that you cannot escape it but you don't
have to be part of it do not participate
in it and that is it's a great it's an
overwhelming pressure and that's why you
know we'd say to the parents please
appreciate the challenges that these
young men and women are going through
I mean imagine that you are in high
school you are popular you're
good-looking you are active you are no
one and sometimes you may not be any of
that but yet somebody comes and they
express interest in you and there is
that age when we want to be acknowledged
by the opposite gender a woman want to
be told by a man that she's beautiful
that she looks nice a man wants to be
told that he is you know he has got her
attention and that is just it's it's
music to our ears to know that we've
been acknowledged and noticed by the
opposite gender now the question is you
appreciate and that's just part of the
natural development and growth that we
go through as human beings but as
parents make sure that you always have a
healthy alternative if we do not have
happy homes where we are validated by
our parents where we are encouraged by
our parents and we are not we don't know
or at least it has not been
verbalize to us that we are loved by our
parents we would look for love somewhere
else so we would say at that point it is
a challenge not only to that sister not
only to that brother but it's also a
challenge to the entire family what kind
of alternatives can we create so that
our children do not fall into it now
what about the the individuals who are
like you said you know it's it's music
to the ear the woman she wants to be
told she's beautiful so she's putting
herself out there on Facebook on MySpace
and you know the the boy also he's on
the hunt and he just put another number
now he just got another you know victim
and the boy has bragging what rights the
girl she's like you know trying to get
that status of being the hottest girl
and it's a game it becomes like a cycle
just a game and you know many women some
of them you know they we want to give
them the facts so they're naive to a lot
of this and they they fall for these you
know sweet nothings and the boy who
shouldn't be doing this what advice do
we have for them sure you know here's
the thing
remember this if how we feel about
ourselves is going to determine is going
to be determined by what other people
say or think of us then we are doomed
how we feel about ourselves should not
really come from what other people tell
us about ourselves now it may enhance
how we already feel about ourselves but
to just wait for validation from
somebody else then we are giving and
surrendering a lot of power to that
person I will only feel beautiful when
he tells me I am beautiful
I will only feel important what she says
that I am that is a lot of power people
don't know how much power we are giving
away to other people when we fall into
that so it's all it really comes back
again to the subjugation of the passion
recognize that it's really nice it is
music to the east but you know what
right now I'll be singing that music to
my ears are not somebody else will be
singing it for me and I think that is
key here self discipline and self
control it's interesting also because
the Prophet salah salem speaks about
about the speech be upon him and he says
that truly a believer is the one who
takes pleasure in the good that they
have done
and more minimum sorrow to a husana to
who so now how we feel about ourselves
does not come from what people say or
think about us but rather it is our own
commitment to what our principles and
values say to be like we're going to
take a break and we'll right back with
more here we go sir for saga and the
Dean shall sit tight
Robin you can take my daughter to dinner
you and my daughter and me and let me
tell you something it's natural I guess
the idea God created it and he created
us to have a good time you should have a
good time only without wives though
Islam is the fastest growing religion in
the world and most of the converts are
women not men they see that the rules of
Islam instead of constraining it the
rules set them free oh can you put your
dream home and you've got your dream car
but you're going to get old and things
are going to happen to you in your life
and then what have you got at the end of
the day is an empty dream that has no
real foundation we are gonna die and
we're gonna meet our Lord and he is
going to judge us it becomes an
obligation for each single human being
to find out what the Quran is Islam is
telling us to stay away from things
which are bad for your person in bed for
the society it's killing of innocent
human beings human life is precious back
here on the Dean show with Sheikh Yusuf
oars Agha and we have so many things to
talk about on this topic so little time
so we just want to leave the people with
some good information so good advice and
hopefully we can we can get this sister
now to feel better to be on a road
towards healing up and not going back to
that and people can benefit from her
question now one note on her okay she
realized what she did she shouldn't have
done she shouldn't have been in this
relationship from from the get-go right
that's clear
marriage is the way to go in Islam right
yes okay she gets the phone call now
she's healing up boys will be boys he's
not on the correct way he's not doing
the right thing and he's hungry he wants
to eat you know what I'm talking about
he calls up at 1:00 2:00 in the morning
hey baby and he started he still has her
number right what do you
well this is what we say this is about
avoiding a relapse you know and the best
thing at that point I actually had a
client was in a situation like this you
know the guy got what he wanted
and then by the end of the day and
unfortunately squeezing an orange
squeeze all the juice out of it and then
would he do with the rest of it he
throws it away
yeah but then he I guess took him some
time to find somebody else didn't know
where to go
he still had her number wants to call
her up again please remember this Eddy
you know the word love in Islam in the
Quran appears in over 90 places love and
its derivatives what is interesting is
it does not define what love is but
speaks about the very first consequence
of love now if you claim to love a
person what would be the very first
consequence of you saying that I love
that person commitment so Islam talks
about commitment if you truly love then
commit if you do not commit then your
claim of love is not real so for that
sister if that kid is really interested
in the essay what I want you to meet my
parents I want you to come and propose
and that's when I'll you know not really
now I am not ready for it well then
you're seeking me for pleasure at this
point and I do not and I'm not going to
put myself out there just to please you
which is what has happened in the our in
the past I don't assume but it seems
like you know now that they're broken up
if he wants her back just for this
I'd say please test his commitment and
say if that's what you want I want you
to talk to my parents and I remember
when I told this to my client he
actually called her and he said you know
I really miss your baby and you know he
was singing all that bright tunes in
paris' late at night like you said 120
maybe 125 yeah but then he said you know
he said all the right things and she
started falling for it and then no she
remembered what we talked about in
counseling and she said you know what
that sounds really sweet I want you to
meet my pair
and that music absolutely changed said
you know I'm still I can't and that that
is that study was out it was gathering
at that boy and he could not complete a
sentence yeah and she immediately knew
what he was after was not necessarily
what she wanted and at that point I am
NOT going to open myself up so that you
take what you want and then you're going
to toss me as you have done this in the
indie past so please you know stand your
stand your ground and remember remember
this you know what never change who you
are to please somebody else if we just
keep doing this all the time the person
who is in relationship with that person
is no longer us it is somebody else and
what good is it that we lose who we are
in order to be with somebody who does
not like us the way with that we are I'm
not I'm not hesitant or shy to use such
strong language here because I love our
sisters we love our women in Islam we
love our sisters in humanity so even if
you're not one who has consciously
submitted to the one god you're not
doing the way of life of all the
messengers of god islam we still want
the best for you so when i use such
harsh language and say beware of the
dogs because a dog he wants to eat when
he's hungry so that wolf in sheep's
clothing beware of them don't fall for
these tricks and this is that good
advice that make him come through the
front door so he don't go through the
back by all means
and see and here's the thing and i'm not
denouncing us as men but we really do
have the ability to sing all the right
music you know I deal a lot with women
who are in abusive relationships
the average woman in the u.s. who is in
an abusive relationship remains in that
relationship an average of 18 to 25
years this is somebody who is physically
verbally mentally psychologically
sexually abusing the woman yet she stays
with him for an average of 18 to 25
years I have counseled women who got out
after twenty-one years 19 years 20 years
and what have you
but what is most common about them is
this guy knows how to load them back in
he knows how to say he knows what to say
he just knows which buttons to push and
you know what they read them so
unbelievably well and I think and please
don't hold that against me but I think
that some of the greatest psychologists
are actually pimps because of their
ability to come out they read a person
and just be able to press all the right
buttons on that on that on that person
you know so we would say we would say
police if anybody claims love then ask
for commitment because they said they
love you it does not give them the
license to sleep with you okay you want
to make sure that because this is it's
not just a physical act but rather great
sex is sex that actually has emotions
with it
it has genuine emotions with it and if
he loves and then wants to be with you
then they should be ready to commit to
you if they're not willing to do so
then I would really question them and a
message now to the parents who sometimes
hinder this great task you prepare your
child to be a doctor and a scientist and
an engineer you're prepping him for this
making sure he goes to the right
institutions and you're helping him or
her along her way but now marriage
you're not taking them to the right
classes sitting with the right people
listening to the right lectures to
prepare them and now even that peer
pressure starts to peer in
peers in and now they end up doing it
the wrong way what advice for the
parents do you have so they don't
contribute to this harm you know Eddie a
cardinal mistake that we as parents make
is that we teach our children how to
make a living but not how to make a life
mm-hmm what good is it that I know how
to make a living but my life is really a
mess yes preparing us to be a good man a
good woman by giving us you know these
valuable lessons and it's not being
afraid of you know knowing what our
challenges um our challenges are so as
important as it is to teach us how to
make a living more important is to teach
us how to make
and I think if we know how to make a
life then we would know how to make a
living but because we know how to make a
living it does not necessarily mean that
we know how to make a life
so please especially in today's culture
be aware of the different challenges
that you know our children go through
Newsweek magazine had a poll asking
children what was you know what was most
influential in their lives parents were
not number one not number two not number
three not number four not number five
not number six they came in seventh they
came after school teachers friends
celebrities magazines and what have you
so please do not lose that place of
authority you are the best teacher you
are a teacher who is emotionally
invested in the well-being of your of
your children and because of this
address the real challenges life issues
life related issues and I mean come on
nowadays sex relationships is all over
the place and if you are not willing to
talk to your children about these issues
somebody else is somebody else is and I
am so thankful grateful that they came
to us and we got to talk about this very
important issue and we look forward to
having you again here in the Dean shall
we start at Pease we end with peace
people of you thank you
so Nikhil alaikum Salaam and thank you
thank you for sentai to another episode
of the Deen show I hope you got to
benefit from the sisters question and an
advice that we got to give her and
everyone out there don't get caught by
that wolf in sheep's clothing
don't let that person come to the back
door make them go through the front door
make them meet your parents and talk to
your parents have an open relationship
with the parents and the parents with
the children and stick to the game plan
the game plan that was revealed by the
creator of the heavens and earth and
that's that total and complete
submission to the one who created you
living life according to his will not
your desires and at the end there's
nothing less than paradise that's right
paradise and we hope that you will come
back here every week to the Deen show
until next time peace be unto you